we start again
my name is rich Pato some people know me
as RB I'm the founder and CEO of stage
32 which is the world's largest online
platform for connecting and educating
film creatives and content creators and
all them professionals worldwide I'm
also an actor just appeared in a movie
that was filmed at Sundance didn't
premiere at Sundance it was filmed at
Sundance also a screenwriter and
producer this had films that have played
at Sundance and can and the author of
crowdsourcing for filmmakers which I'm
sure we're going to talk about
a lot of people confuse crowdsourcing
with crowd funding there are two totally
different things and I was approached to
write this book because of a talk that I
gave at AFM a few years back and and
because of my presence on social media
and my ability to audience build and the
fact that stage 32 as a platform was
completely crowdsource we crowdsource
the entire community and what I mean by
that is that it's all been built by word
of mouth we started with a hundred
people hundred of my industry friends
and colleagues that were members of the
community and now there's over a half
million people worldwide because we
asked the community to carry the word
which is sort of the basis of
crowdsourcing and that's how we've
gotten to a half a million people
worldwide on the platform
well Jonathan wolf who runs the American
film market and is a really progressive
guy he's a really really smart
individual in his head unlike a lot of
festival runners and even people that
run some of the markets he really sees
ahead of the curve and he understood
that in this DIY world that we were
entering and that were actually in now
back then we were entering it that
crowdsourcing and building an audience
when you're controlling your own
material is paramount it's just so
important and you know he asked me to
head up a panel of people that
understood this space people working at
production companies that create content
that involved crowdsourcing to be on
this panel at AFM and we were really
excited about it because again people
just didn't understand what we were
talking about they kept thinking the
panel was about crowdfunding when it was
about crowdsourcing so when I got asked
to write the book
AFM presents they usually pick about two
titles a year out of the focal press
rutledge catalog to be part of their
banner or to be published under their
banner and and this was one of them and
I couldn't be more excited about it
crowd funding at its most base is
raising funds for a project either
through equity based crowdfunding or
rewards based crowdfunding equity being
that you have an ownership share based
on your investment in the project or in
the product rewards base is the one that
people more people are familiar with of
course which is where you receive some
sort of either you know a chatzky or up
to a credit you know for giving funds to
a project crowd sourcing at its most
base is all about identifying engaging
and moving an audience on behalf of you
your projects the brand of you the brand
of your projects to build a groundswell
of support you know build an army of
boots on the ground if you will in
support of you and your projects that's
at its most at its simplest form
right now we're living in a you know
it's a Content rich environment you know
there's more television being it created
than ever before there are more outlets
for independent film than ever before
with streaming platforms and more
networks moving into original
programming even into original not only
original series but limited series as
well so but there's also the opportunity
for so many filmmakers in the digital
space and and short-form content
creators in the digital space to create
their own content and control their own
content and that's the big thing to me
the big thing to me is how much do you
want to control controlling your content
is such a big part of it right now and
to do that you have to know how to
crowdsource because there are so many
people that are doing it how do you rise
above the crowd it's not only just your
content that has to stand out look if
you create content and a volley and even
a vacuum
nobody's gonna see it right you have to
be able to build an audience for that
content and that begins way way before
you even go into pre-production you
should be thinking about who the
audience is who you're looking to target
identifying them and engaging them
giving them ownership getting them
involved and then you can move them and
that's why it's so important because
again so many people are trying to
create content but people don't know how
to get that content viewed they don't
know who the audience is they mistake
the fact that they think that everybody
is the audience for their projects when
really there is a specific audience that
they just haven't identified yet that's
how you stand out from the crowd and the
people that the people that know how to
crowdsource the people that understand
how to do that
absolutely have a competitive advantage
in the space not to mention the fact
that production companies managers
agents you name it look at the ability
to bring an audience with you as sort of
been a weird way as the new IP you know
a year ago what everything that was
involved was is this based on anything
isn't this project baseline anything but
you know are you bringing an audience
that is already familiar with this IP
well now it doesn't matter if it's
existing IP what matters is if you've
built an audience or groundswell for
that product and that project on your
own already people are going to be more
likely to say wow you've already proven
that people like this that their
interests
and you're gonna get more serious looks
and more serious attention and that's
why it's monumentally important
I mean the beauty of the book is that I
was able to talk to a bunch of
filmmakers and producers even actors and
screenwriters and I should say that the
book is called crowdsourcing for
filmmakers but it really is for all
creatives and really it's for everybody
I mean even if you have a business or if
you have a product it's only cool
crowdsourcing for filmmakers because
focal rutledge that's what they focus on
is is film I would have preferred it to
be called crowdsourcing for film
creatives because everything that we're
going to talk about is true for actors
writers producers finance ears it
doesn't matter it's all about branding
and building that audience and building
that support so I was able to talk to
probably 100 to 150 people at least that
I interviewed for this book and came
away with some pretty amazing case
studies there's probably there's three
big ones actually four big ones in the
book including the story of stage 32 and
how we crowdsource the community but
then three film ones one's a documentary
one's a short ones a feature to show how
these producers crowd-sourced everything
not only from their not just their
audience but locations and camera
equipment and you name it there are a
million different ways to crowdsourcing
the names of characters I mean you name
it and that allowed us to have probably
about you know 15 to 20 cases ladies and
all in the books and some of capsules so
you know short form case studies and the
other or a long form one of my favorites
is a documentary called mile mile and a
half and it's a really interesting story
and it encompasses everything that we
talked about about audience building
which at the core of crowdsourcing is
what we're talking about is audience
building but it's also about the fact
that you could source anything and
that's what I love about this story this
is a documentary that five
cinematographers and one sound engineer
decided that they wanted to do they're
all fitness freaks so they decided that
they were going to go on a hike together
they were gonna go do a camping thing
and they started thinking about this
further and they said why don't we go
hike the John Muir Trail and the John
Muir Trail is about a two hundred and
six mile hike in the Pacific Northwest
where you have to get I thinking about
maybe 50 permits a year where you could
hike the whole thing you could hide
parts of it
but to hype the whole thing you need a
special permit and they said why don't
we go you know film this thing let's
take the most state-of-the-art equipment
video wise audio wise and film all these
different ecosystems in a way that never
has never been seen before cuz most
people haven't seen it it's sort of this
thing in America that people don't
really know about it they haven't seen
it on film and they said well let's go
bring that to the public doesn't seem
like a really sexy documentary in a lot
of ways and they wanted to go out and
they wanted 3d CG $5,000 which is an
enormous number for a documentary for
this subject matter but here's what they
did that was really cool they said okay
let's think about who the audience is
for this film which should be the first
question that anyone should be asking
when the crowd for any project for any
project anyway you should ask who your
audience is for this film and they said
okay well we know who's gonna really
like it the nature freaks the health of
the health and fitness buffs the people
who love camping the outdoorsman the
outdoors women they're gonna love it but
let's see if we could expand that and
they said you know what why do we want
to do this well we want to do this just
with gearheads
because we love film we love
documentaries and they said well let's
go to the people that probably love the
same so they went to all the gearhead
boards and everything like that and they
started telling them look this and I'm
talking this is like six months before
they even launched the crowdfunding
campaign so this is a long time okay and
this is why because audience building
takes a long time but they went to all
these different groups and they said
look this is what we're looking to do
are we crazy what should we be thinking
about what should we you know how should
we you know sort of running contests for
example like you know we're gonna be
traveling heavy with all the equipment
how do we travel light food wise what
kind of meals can we carry in a camping
car you know and people started writing
in and what they were doing were was
they were identifying their audience and
then engaging and then they were giving
them ownership they were saying help us
you know be a part of what we're doing
you know how many miles a day is too
much what kind of footwear should we
wear all of this stuff and what ended up
happening was there was this sort of
really interesting groundswell of
support that went on and then what
happened even better was that some of
these people got so behind them they
started writing equipment companies and
camping equipment and even even
electronics companies and camera
companies and saying check out what
these guys are doing and they started
getting contacted by these companies who
started donating equipment and donating
camping gear and then REI got involved
of all things REI is a gigantic outdoors
company they gave them all the equipment
they said you could take it all this is
so awesome we're gonna write about it on
the blog just mention us in the credits
just give us a thank you and here you go
so they were crowdsourcing equipment
they were crowdsourcing everything by
the time they went to turn on their
crowdfunding campaign six months later
and they finally asked this audience
that they identified and they had
engaged and who had a given value to and
ownership to when they asked them to
move they moved like that and that
$85,000 was raised in four days I
believe it was four days and they hit
their goal that quickly and they
surpassed their goal what was better and
this is a big part of it
they continued to deliver on their
promises even after they got into post
production they didn't just film the
movie and then disappear they were
giving them there was showing them
pictures and in the post-production and
giving them added extra you know scenes
that weren't gonna be in the movie they
kept giving value and giving value when
the film finally premiered at the LA
Film Festival they had to open up
another theater because so many people
showed up okay that's the first time
it's happened in the festival's history
when the movie got released on iTunes it
went to number two in the first day
behind hero Dreams of Sushi and it is
very difficult to crack the top ten on
documentaries especially they won on
iTunes
but this was the groundswell of support
they still to this day reach out to
everybody reach out and they keep
talking about the next film these
backers are ready to just run through a
wall for them this is the army of boots
on the ground that they built up and
they have a lot of other gear companies
still saying next movie you tell us what
you need next movie you know whatever
you need us to do that's crowd sourcing
at its finest and that's why I love that
story
first thing you got to do is you have to
be honest with yourself you have to be
honest with who your audiences you know
filmmakers screenwriters actors you know
any content creator we all like to think
that we all want to be universally loved
we all want to be you know we want
everybody to love our work and love what
we do but the reality of this situation
is that there's an audience for
everybody and you have to know who that
audience is and that is the single most
important part of taking the first step
in crowd sourcing who is my audience
it's the first question you have to ask
yourself and then you have to you have
to answer it honestly and that part
might be even more harder than really
answering the first question honestly
okay if you think about your favorite
film of all time okay your favorite
author your favorite piece of art your
favorite anything is universally loved
does everybody else love it no the
answer is no you'll find the tractors
everywhere and there's reasons why you
know I love The Godfather I like mob
movies other people may not I like you
know thrillers and action movies other
people hate them you have to know who
your audience is and you have to know
who you're targeting and then the second
thing is right behind that is you have
to know how to engage in a selfless way
what am I going to give everything
having to do it with relationship
building an audience building begins and
ends with the value not the value that
they can give you okay that's for later
all right if you're identifying him you
already know what the value proposition
is going to be at the end what the value
ask is going to be at the end but
they're not going to come with you if
you're not bringing value so it's all
about how do you identify them and how
do you engage them in a selfless way and
that's something you can to do today but
the bigger thing is the reason why
crowdsourcing works and the reason why
it you know is something that is so
important is because the people that put
in the time when you build those
relationships and you build what
ultimately sometimes become a friendship
sometimes they just become business you
know relationships or whatever that
value carries on for a long period of
time
but it but it's work and it's why so
many people surrender they don't they
don't want to put in the work they just
want to create something and have people
see it and that's not the way it works
it's a long game it's a long game and
you have to be willing to put in the
time
everything on social media begins with
being selfless everything you know I
like to say that when you sign up for a
social media account you being handed a
microphone but so is everybody else
everyone's being handed a microphone the
question is what do you do with it
95% of the people that get handed that
microphone go huh I think you know look
at me look at me look at me yeah and and
that becomes you know just the din you
know what I mean like it's just it's
like being next to power lines like and
you know you don't need nothing you know
nothing comes through you like that
nothing comes through if you're using
that microphone to say here's a really
great piece of content that I found that
I think you guys will like thank you
know engaging with somebody saying thank
you for sharing that piece of content
thank you for being a part of my network
hey you know I really enjoyed that film
you made and here's why you're making it
about other people you're bringing value
to other people I always say there's
three ways that you can you know
everybody some people say like I'm not
good at social media or I don't feel
like I have a place on social media and
my answer is everybody has a place on
social media and here are your entry
points okay share content be
complimentary okay and be grateful those
are the ways that you can get in alright
everyone is accessible on social media
if you're on Twitter let's say or even
on stage 32 for that matter you can
reach anybody at any time but the
difference between the people that are
able to engage other people and those
that get radio silence is approach its
value it's what you bring to the party
you have to come from a place of
selflessness and if you don't you can
expect that silence and that's why so
many people quit social media because
they don't get anything out of it but
they're not bringing anything and you
have to bring something it's called
social media by the way not me media
that they don't need to that if you
build it they will come a lot of
filmmakers just it's not filmmakers
again it's screenwriters attack theirs
its content creators of any kind its
producers you know they think their
greatness is going to shine through or
the the originality of the project let's
say or the brilliance and their mind
that the project is gonna win the day
and look there is a lot of content out
there and there are a lot of really good
writers and filmmakers and actors and
you know I've heard people say to me on
them let's take it from different
direction and go into the music business
I've had people say to me God have seen
this band so many times and they're so
amazing it's incredible they never got a
deal they never get anything but then
you go to watch them play and they have
five people in the audience because they
don't know how to build an audience they
don't know how and they don't know how
to draw attention okay they don't know
how to show what they're all about
that is so monumentally important that's
why I'm saying if you could build an
audience for you and your brand and you
are a brand and people don't realize
that's who you are a brand you have to
identify what that brand is and then you
have to project that brand forward okay
but if you are not doing that people
aren't gonna know about it all right
nobody's gonna guess and you have to get
people a reason and beyond it's a great
film man you gotta check it out or like
hey I just wrote the greatest screenplay
and I hear this stuff all the time but
there's no proof and there's no social
proof of that and there's no army and
there's no champions behind that and if
there's none of that then again you're
gonna get radio silence so it's people
think that it's all about the craft and
it's not about the craft it's about the
craft it is about the crab but it's
about the craft plus knowing the
business and knowing the industry
knowing all of it and about your
relationships relationships are
everything in this business everything I
don't care what crafts you toiling and I
think if you crew okay
relationships are everything your brand
is everything and how you cultivate that
defines you
look if you're famous and you know the
the Josh Whedon or the Zach Braff kind
of thing where you could just turn it on
because people know who you are sure you
know people are gonna back you because
they know you but that is part of there
was a time where those people had to
crowdsource an audience just as well
they've just carried it forward to the
point now where they're a brand slack
Braff is a brand Joss Whedon's a brand
but for the first time filmmaker the
first time crowd sorcerer the answer in
my opinion is no unless you have friends
and family of course that are going to
donate the whole thing which in that
case you really don't need the
crowdfunding aspect of it but the whole
idea behind crowdfunding is that you're
sourcing an audience and that's why I
don't believe that that's the case if
you look again we talked about a mile
and a half or any of these other
examples even that are in the book where
there was a crowdfunding aspect you'll
see that the common denominator was well
before they launched that kind of
campaign they went out and sourced this
audience and got them so riled up and
gave them ownership of this project to
the point where they said hey listen in
a few months we're going to turn this
thing on will you take this journey with
us and that's what a really good
crowdfunding campaign manager or a
person running a crowdfunding campaign
once they identify engage that audience
and engage that audience they get them
to the point where they say you know
will you take this journey with us it's
not will you donate well will you take
this ride with us and if you get people
to that point that's when they want to
jump in with you so I don't believe I
think it's the biggest mistake that
people who run crowdfunding campaigns
make and I think it's the reason why so
many crowdfunding campaigns fail is
because they're not sourcing for months
before they start the campaign and then
what ends up happening is they get into
desperation mode you know they find
themselves three weeks in and they're
out by 20 percent of their goal and then
they go on to social media and then they
start DMing you and saying hey please
back doesn't mark it doesn't work I've
had so many people that have hit me up
that you know you don't have a
relationship with them and they just hit
you up and they DM you and they're like
oh you got to check out this project and
then you go and you look at it and you
know there are week three and they're at
like 7 percent of their goal and you
could see why because the strategy is
the people that win the day and look I
have friends at IndieGoGo I have friends
at Kickstarter
I have campaign manager friends that
this is what they do for a living
and when they get involved in the
project or when the people that head up
the film Department said IndieGoGo or
Kickstarter get behind the project or
even doesn't even have to be filmed when
they get behind the tech project its
heck product they all say the same thing
don't run before you can walk don't
press that launch button yet we're gonna
spend three to six months building an
audience for this getting people excited
about it get giving people ownership of
it okay and then we're gonna move why do
you think the reason why so many tech
products do better what a tech product
crowdfunding campaigns do better than
film on a success average the reason is
people get excited about the product
people that want that own these products
ask what features do you want to see
what else are we missing what do we and
then what do they give them they let
them preorder it so they they want it
it's tangible but for a film it's not
tangible
what's tangible is the fact that you
feel like you're a part of it that you
feel like you're involved in it that you
feel like you're on set with them when
they go to start filming you know I mean
like you're part of this thing I back
that thing and I'm proud of it that
doesn't happen when you just throw up a
campaign and then start asking people
that you don't know who have no
investment no involvement with you to
donate so yeah you know I don't believe
that you could have a successful
crowdfunding campaign without
crowdsourcing it's just doesn't work
it's the brand of view of the Baron that
your project I think is what you're
getting at and it should be the brand if
you're a first-timer it should be the
brand of your project here so I'm going
to illustrate this okay again I want you
to think about your favorite filmmaker
okay that man a woman that no matter
what they're making you're going to the
theater to go see that film okay I'll
give you an example PT Anderson is one
of my favorite filmmakers okay when
Hardy came out I knew nothing about
Petey Anderson I wouldn't know him Petey
Anderson from any other Anderson on the
street but what I did know and what my
friends knew was that I liked
independent dramas they knew I liked
gambling movies and movies about you
know Redemption stories they knew a kind
of movie I like they knew that this was
right in my wheelhouse so I had friends
that were going to film festivals as
saying to me you have to see this movie
hearty and I went to go see it and I was
like wow this is a really really good
movie but also as somebody to love
cinema I said this is a really good
filmmaker
who is this guy okay and I learned more
about him and I knew at that time that
he was you know whatever he was at the
time 23 24 years old and that he had
written and directed this thing and I
said wow this guy has got some serious
chops so now I went from being a fan of
the movie okay to a fan of him not
totally yet I wasn't totally convinced
yet because this is one project and I'm
like okay let's see what he does not
well what he did next of course was
Boogie Nights and I went to go see
Boogie Nights thinking about that
theater and I said I don't care what
this guy does for the rest of his life
I'm going because now I am a fan of him
and the brand the PT and this and in PT
Anderson certainly has a brand it's the
same thing with you as a content creator
as a writer an actor a producer a
filmmaker it doesn't matter okay at
first it is always going to be about the
brand of your work the project okay so
if you're a first-time filmmaker for
example and you're putting up a
crowdfunding campaign people are going
to back the project because of if you're
if you're crowdsourcing correctly the
content of the project because you've
identified people who are going to be
supporters of the content of the project
for example
use this in the book but let's say it's
a baseball movie you're gonna go out to
every baseball organization people you
know you're gonna hit everybody on
Twitter that is shown an affinity for
baseball comp movies you know that are
in the space you're gonna go to chat
boards and everything else
and you're gonna let them know about
what you're looking to do and then
you're gonna give them ownership you're
gonna say hey here's a little bit of the
plot what have I missed what am i doing
you know hi hey I'm gonna name the dog
today I you know dog in the script is an
Irish Setter who wants to name the dog
and you give them ownership and Oh
so-and-so won the contest to name the
dog you get them involved you get them
involved you get them involved they're
fans of the project but every step along
the way you are providing them with
value and then you have the opportunity
okay to deliver on every single promise
that you made I'm gonna make this movie
it's gonna be exactly the way we talked
about I'm gonna bring it in on time I'm
gonna send you like I said pitches from
the set extras from the set I'm gonna be
you know interviewing the actors and
sending them saying hi and all this
stuff and whatever and I'm gonna deliver
the best film that I can deliver if you
do that the whole way through guess what
happens they cease to become well
they'll always be fans of the brand of
the film but now they're fans of the
brand of you and now if your next movie
is a 180 from your baseball movie you
know it's a musical setting you know the
1920s they don't care okay they want to
follow you into fire so at first is
about the brand that a project and then
it's about the brand of you and then as
you move along if you continue to
deliver on your promise promises it's
the brand of you the brand of you the
brand of you the brand of you all the
way through
also to release that that's a great
question well crowdsourcing has always
been sort of inbred in me why not you
know I used to run a magazine called
razor that was a men's lifestyle
magazine you competed against GQ and
Esquire and we used very because we
didn't have the finances of the funding
to compete in a lot of ways with the
advertising and marketing of a GQ or an
Esquire we relied on our audience to
carry the message of our brand which
when in a lot of ways was very simply
one of our slogans was when you you know
don't raise the magazines from when
you're done with your Maxim years but
not ready for your Esquire years now men
that read our magazine love that and
they were carrying the message and they
were like you got to check out this
magazine guy so we were crowdsourcing
back then obviously which stage 32 it's
been the same thing like I said earlier
this is you know stage 32 started with a
hundred of my industry friends and I
asked them straight up I said look
you're in now you're a part of this
community go invite at least five people
to come join us to help strengthen this
thing my word-of-mouth is a big part of
crowdsourcing okay the word of another
in support of you is greater than your
word if somebody doesn't know you so
what I was basically saying is I can go
to your colleagues I can go to your
friends and say hey come join stage 32
but they're gonna be like who the hell
are you but if you tell them and you
tell them that what I'm doing is worthy
of their time they're gonna say well
yeah we're gonna check that out and
that's why we wanted to crowdsource
which stage 32 that's ask people to go
do that well with this book it's really
been no different people have known when
I first signed the contracts for this
book and it was about two years before
it came out because it was again a ton
of interviews and a ton of research but
the day I signed the contracts I let
everybody know I'm doing this okay and
here's what I need from you if you've
crowd-sourced something before tell me
about it if you've had a failed
crowdfunding campaign if you can't get
traction on social media if you've quit
social media I want to know it wasn't
even so much hearing the success stories
as it was hearing the failure stories
because I wanted to be able to help
people who had had those failures on top
of knowing that would be easier to
the success stories in a lot of ways I
wanted to talk to the people that you
know had struggled and what were those
struggles what do you need me to write
about what needs to be in this book so
from day one from the day I signed the
contracts with focal and rutledge it was
all about giving people ownership it was
all about going out to people on social
media or people in my you know I have a
pretty big social media following so
going to those people and saying look
I'm writing this book I want you to
write me privately send me what's going
on
you know if you've had struggles send
them to me and I started sourcing an
audience two years before the book went
into play and you know started letting
people know as I was writing the book
look here are some subjects I'm planning
on writing on here are some chapter
titles that I'm working on what do you
think of that here are you know not
here's not only a chapter but what's
gonna be in the chapter is there
anything you feel I'm missing under this
subject that you feel you know would be
helpful or that you've experienced that
I'm not covering and everybody got into
it everybody was like wow this is really
really really cool and you had a bunch
of infusion with the crowdsourcing
crowdfunding thing but that also give
any opportunity to educate people to say
like this is what the book is gonna be
about but lo and behold and you know
don't don't fret there is gonna be stuff
about crowds
crowdfunding in the book you know and
there are two chapters on crowdfunding
originally I was gonna put two chapters
on crowdfunding because I wanted to keep
it on the crowdsourcing level but people
were saying to me if you really believe
that they can't be a successful
crowdfunding campaign without
crowdsourcing included in the book do a
couple of chapters so I did but that
came from the audience so you know I
learned from the early from raiser and
from stage 32 that this works and this
is absolutely important and I did not
want to write this book in a vacuum I
wanted to write it with contributions
from stage 32 members my Twitter
followers my Instagram followers
everybody everybody and there's a lot of
everybody in this book which is great
the amount of things that people sourced
at times was a little surprising there
is another great case study in the book
for a movie called risen star and they
crowd-sourced locations
I mean it's fascinating they had to
shoot the script call for them to shoot
at government buildings and places where
especially for a short on a limited
budget you know you don't have a lot of
money for locations with painful
locations of course but it's certainly
to pay for you know the via government
buildings and to convince them to let
you do that is something else but they
were able to you know build up this
groundswell of support in the community
because it was about the story was about
unemployment what was going on with
people in the area to convince
government officials to say you know
what we'll give you the locations but
here's what we want you know you
premiere this movie at town at the city
hall I mean that's amazing I mean it's
amazing but you know it was the fact
that really anything could be sourced
and it's the fact that you know you're
only bounded by your only limitations
are really you know bounded by the the
excesses I guess of your mind or the
weight of your mind as far as your mind
can reach in a way
there's only one solution and that's not
to neglect it you have to know what's
going on in the industry I mean you have
to again for me look you know I don't
want it to be lost than anybody watching
this video that I'm not just the founder
of stage 32 and you know I am an actor a
writer and a producer and those things
call for me to be in a very competitive
space all the time just like everybody
watching this video right now it is
incredibly competitive no matter what
I'm looking to do whether I'm looking to
produce a feature or an indie or I'm
trying to get a feature into Sundance
like we were you know back in 2011 with
another happy day I mean it's
competitive and you know it's
competitive so and and even as a
screenwriter
you know I'm wrapped I have things in
development things are moving along I
mean there's more than two or three
scripts that are that are moving along
doesn't matter okay I'm still out to be
my own best advocate and the way but the
way I was able to get to those
situations and be in that position was
because I knew what was going on in the
business I knew who my targets were I
knew who I needed to be talking to I
understood what was happening when I was
walking into a meeting I was prepared at
all times to me everything is about how
do I get a competitive advantage what
gives me a competitive advantage
everything is about that so I said
earlier you know crowdsourcing done
right gives you an amazing competitive
advantage knowing what's going on in the
industry gives you an amazing
competitive advantage because I could
tell you that so many people don't know
and so many people don't take the time
to know and so many people don't take
the time to know who they're dealing
with
they get a meeting and they have no idea
who they didn't do do they research they
don't you have to know it is part of
your job I don't care and I don't care
what craft you're in what craft will you
know anything it doesn't matter you have
to know the business
it would be enormous because the person
that reads the book would understand
everything that goes into building that
building an audience and moving an
audience building and engaging and
moving them and it would give them an
enormous advantage because the strategy
is within or not just the strategy is
that you know I've used and that I've
cultivated through the years and in some
ways perfected in a lot of ways to be
honest with you and I'd say there was no
ego I'm saying that that's you know
trial and error trial and error trial
and error until I got to something that
worked a bunch of getting knocked down
but getting up again knocked down and up
again but it's not just my voice it's
the voices of dozens of filmmakers and
producers and Finance years and
screenwriters within talking about these
same things taking these strategies that
I'm talking about and using them in
their own way you know to find success
and to be able to crowdsource an
audience and in you know relation to
your question raise money for their
projects so it would give you an
enormous advantage in my opinion and I
don't think I'm wrong
yeah relax just relax be yourself you
know treat your online pursuits by the
way crowdsourcing is an online and and
offline endeavor they should not be
different the the benefit of online of
course is that you know you could reach
anybody at anytime and that's the beauty
of it but that means you also have to
put in the time and you have to put in
the work it is work and you have to be
willing to do it and those who I always
say you could separate who's serious and
who isn't by the people that all they
care about is the craft the craft the
craft the craft and they don't worry
about all the other stuff that goes
around it you have to relax you have to
have a plan as we said earlier you have
to know who your audience is come up
with 30 days of social media post
challenge yourself to come up with 30
days of sharing content or whatever
spend one night saying you know what for
the next two hours on social media I'm
just gonna go meet people and compliment
them or I'm gonna make a target list and
I'm within that target list maybe ten
people okay but I'm gonna have something
to say to all ten of those people that
are gonna be about them that I did some
research on that they're gonna be
astonished that somebody knew about me
in an effort to engage them in an effort
to get them to know who I am
challenge yourself all the time you're
not gonna get ten responses in that
scenario you're probably not but if you
get one out of ten two out of ten three
out of ten it's still two or three
contacts that you can build on and
that's what it's all about it's building
relationships if you think about your
best friendships that you've had in your
life or you have in your life those
things took time it wasn't like you met
them one night out somewhere and the
next day you were like oh we're gonna be
best friends forever no it takes time
and it takes trust and it takes you
bringing value to the relationship and
that's exactly what social media and
audience building is all about so what
you're on my offline efforts all about
you don't go to a conference and meet
somebody for the first time and you're
making a movie with them the next day
it's very rare that that happens I
should say but you know it takes time to
build up trust and to make the other
person understand that you're always
going to be bringing value to the
relationship and but the people that do
it win the day more often than they're
not and more than I'd and my whole goal
every single day
when I open in the morning I'm like how
am I gonna win today so that's what you
have to think about how am I gonna win
today but just relax and just do it and
don't worry about being judged and don't
worry about you know put out great
content be a great communicator come
from a place of selflessness obey the
rule of three which in which the rule of
three very simply is you know be
selfless three times before you ask for
anything yourself give give give before
you ever ask for anything and that first
ask should not be for the world you know
it just might be can you and I noticed
that you know somebody can you introduce
me to them can you be you know you're
winning champions okay but winning
champions begins with selflessness and
do that and I promise you you win more
days than you lose
you can find crowdsourcing for
filmmakers which again I just want to
say for all creatives all businesspeople
I'll give your CEO by the way if you are
creative you are an entrepreneur you are
a CEO you're the CEO of you that's very
important treat your life as a business
treat your pursuits as a business
creature audience building and
relationship building as a business be
the CEO of you but this is for all
creatives you can find the book on
Amazon it's available in eBook and and
paperback obviously it's also available
on focal presses site as well I don't
know the exact web site for focal press
but if you put in focal press and crowd
sources of filmmakers you'll find it but
it definitely is on Amazon and if you're
watching this overseas you can go
through focal and a number of other
booksellers as well that have the book
in stock thank you thanks for having me
I love film courage love them courage
thanks I would be back